what if i tell you the best course on
react is now free hey everyone my name
is mahul and in this video i'm
announcing the launch of react 18 course
on code dam which is going to be
upgraded throughout the release of react
18 and we're going to be covering a lot
of new stuff plus existing stuff in
react also if you're new here make sure
you like the video and subscribe to the
channel it really helps in order to put
out more free courses and more free
content like this the best part is this
course is 100 free and interactive that
means if you take a look at the course
you're gonna find within the first
section in the introduction to react we
have a bunch of videos let me just go
ahead and play one for example you do a
hello world the first program with react
and the moment you complete this video
you have an exercise which you have to
perform which is you have to do in hello
world yourself this is how goddam works
it boots a complete environment for you
within seconds where you have to perform
a task whatever it says and do complete
it in a manner where you would probably
just write code in the real world as
well so you can see our first challenge
here is to have a div with an id of app
so
let's just say
i have created an app here and this
should have
and hello world text written so the
moment we do that what you're gonna see
is it runs your code and it will update
you with
if it is right or not and in this case
we pass both the tests so we can move on
to the next one so we start with create
root summary activating features and so
on but the point here is the important
point here is that this course is 100
interactive with a lot of projects at
the end so you have to complete and
create these full-blown projects by the
end of the course which will help you in
order to become a better developer by
actually writing code which is like the
super important thing which i talk to
you all time basically i'm also randomly
gonna give one person a free go damn pro
license if you comment on this video on
your review for the react course and
what do you feel about goddamn platforms
interactive learning in general like the
video leave a comment and i'm gonna give
a one free code damn pro account to
someone in the audience but yeah in
order to check out this free course the
link is in the description it's 100 free
you can check it out it's part of the
full stack learning path as well which
is i mean super awesome if you're trying
to become a full stack developer dude so
do check it out as well if you get time
in order to how you can become a full
stack developer through code dam's
learning path but yeah that's pretty
much it for this video if you liked it
make sure you leave a like and subscribe
to the channel that really helps thank
you all for watching and i'm gonna see
you in the next video really soon
[Music]
you